leave people to go see your Netflix
special this is me now as especially as
I can learn what docking is darkening
it's work that's just that alone betting
is the docking routine yeah I
it's like is where you wrap a foreskin
around the head of non foreskin penis
and they link together and there's a bit
of suction so as soon as you see it you
understand it always makes you think
what will the guys think of so so the
eye I normally do that routine here in
America and then the whole I do a whole
lot of think about how uncircumcised
dicks a gross right and then the
audience of each ear is on my side cuz
Americans for the most part I'd say and
then I find like a guy in the audience
who isn't circumcised then we make the
audience really pick on him and I asked
you know I say say how do you live with
yourself you're disgusting yeah so it's
over the top right mmm
but then I recorded this special in
London where no one circumcised I'll
just give the routine ago anyway so
instead of like everyone cheering is
everyone booing me I was like so it
hasn't even the special hasn't even come
out and I'm expecting a lot of height
mount after that because I'm
circumcision is mutilation blah blah
blah blah blah I'm getting intact
avast's they called what's that and the
people who don't want you what a band
circumcision and the Eagles activists
instructive is they wanna keep in
science there's a word for everything
it's the int activists are showing up at
my case the dictators
yeah and they're like circumcision ruins
sexual pleasure circumcision this
circumcisions mutilation like this right
the funding is Mark fans like they're
all like taking photos in front of the
place
I just love the fact that the people
that come to protest you are pro gun and
anti-circumcision that's your Jim
Jefferies hate groups right there yeah
yeah I'm fine with the show it's like
it's like the it matter people send me
hate mail after the show and it's like
how are you angry at that it's like it's
like me saying in the show I think the
kids should be reunited with the parents
yeah it's like you liberals like okay I
didn't say that they should be let into
the country you know and stuff
I believe illegal is in the title
illegal immigrant but I do not believe
they should be separated from the
parents their children
that's an extra thing right right and
then like the people who are so angry at
me like but you don't [ __ ] welcome to
this [ __ ] country there any like what
that was using jumpers yeah yeah I feel
like people everyone fundamentally
thinks they're a good person right like
you must agree yeah you live with your
personal be so full that you sure you
got some good quality yeah I give I give
waitresses really a large tips every now
and then to get laid yeah like I
remember my young age there was a girl
who used to just brag to her friends the
brat like I'm talking my early twenties
used to brag to her friends like he is
just the sweetest most honest and it's
like more integrity than any man I've
ever met in my entire life and I was
cheating on a constant [ __ ] here I
say these things are dire I'd be like oh
God
[Laughter]